reckless power fragt sie
wie stehst du zu drogen alkohol etc wie
stehe ich dazu gute frage
also ich trinke selber kein alkohol ich
brauche auch keine zigaretten und nimmt
keine drogen und ich würde dir raten
auch nicht zu machen
lebt man wir sind alle s rad 0 69 will
wissen willst du mal heiraten und ich
haben will es ist eine gute frage
inschallah irgendwann warum nicht würde
ich auch gerne einmal auch alabama hat
eine frage an sich sie nahm die wehr ist
deiner meinung nach der beste rapper
also us-rapper mal ist ja wohl eine
frage mein bruder wie die selbe wand
worden
natürlich ist diese person schon längst
erkaltet ist für mich der beste und
bleibt der beste und es wird auch kein
amerikanischer rapper ob ich das little
wayne ist oder drake oder die ganzen
leute ganzen neun leute auch ist niemals
nur ansatzweise einer in zinal kommen
auch nicht egal wer egal wer ist die
nummer 1 bleibt gemeinsam genauso de
leider sitzt deshalb saß er drei jahre
in der jva siegburg ein ja bruder gucken
den tor kein alter hut mit christoph
gesprochen und dort wird das auf jeden
fall erwähnt cook ist die anleihen
bruder und dann ich hoffe dass deine
frage beantwortet wird
passos coelho support hat folgende frage
wie ist es zum kontakt mit codo gekommen
wie es das lied die waffen sind geladen
entstanden schöne größte cordys support
was geht cool und support alter ja ich
hab genug kennen gelernt durch ein
freund er hat mich kontaktiert als er
nach essen gekommen ist eigentlich
kennen gelernt und haben uns getroffen
nahm musik gesetzt gelabert und wir
haben super gut verstanden und
irgendwann haben wir uns gedacht komm
wir machen eins soll aber natürlich
nicht direkt am ersten tag ist weiß
nicht vielleicht ein monat später war so
haben uns gesagt wir machen ein track
und ja und irgendwie ist das
zustandekommen die waffen geladen zu
machen dann haben wir zusammen im studio
eingeladen bei mir zu hause geschlafen
es war drei tage ja oder haben uns ja
ich gedacht haben machen ein festes
video und so entstanden die es wirklich
fragte wann hast du angefangen musik zu
machen musik habe ich angefangen vor 56
jahren
also natürlich habe ich das jetzt 56
jahre richtig durchgezogen so wie man es
von anderen kennt immer neue songs
äußern
ich habe verfügen halt mein erster song
gemacht dann mal den zweiten danach nach
ein zwei jahre habe ich ein album
gemacht dann nach zwei jahren wieder
neigung und ist natürlich das dritte ich
habe jetzt nicht 56 jahre immer
irgendwelche james oder so verbracht und
im nämlichen studios und so das ist
eigentlich meine musikalische laufbahn
ist einfach nur ist das was ich bisher
gemacht habe aber das mache ich so
insgesamt